last month the tampa bay buccaneers
tight end known as grunk retired from
the nfl for the second time the first
time was after nine years with the new
england patriots this sunday gronk will
co-host the usa today high school sports
awards which celebrate the country's
best student athletes earlier he
surprised swimmer claire kerzan from
north carolina with the girls athlete of
the year award take a look
hey claire
hi
what's up it's rob gronkowski here how
you doing
i'm much better now how are you
oh that's good i'm really good i'm just
hanging out
i just want
you know
let you know that you are nominated for
the usa today high school sports awards
girls athlete of the year and you know
i'm hosting the show right
of course i do
so i thought it would be fun to come on
and surprise you here today and i've
been impressed by your high school
career so far you have broken so many
records
at such a young age and on top of all
that
i have some good news for you you aren't
just nominated for the award you are the
winner for girls
here congratulations claire thank you so
much yes pretty incredible how do you
feel about it honestly it's it's an
honor um i know there was a huge list of
incredibly you know acclaimed uh kids so
to think that you know i'm
pretty good too i it's an honor yeah
really congratulations to you claire for
being named girls athlete of the year it
is an honor i know how much work uh goes
into it how much dedication and uh it's
just starting now you got your whole
life out of you and uh you're going to
make dreams come true
oh i really hope so thank you so much
rob gronkowski joins us right now grunk
what's up baby how you doing nate man
what's good man i'm doing well how are
you
i'm good good to have you now listen you
remember being a high school athlete
with your whole life in front of you
what is it like to give out these awards
to these high school student athletes
uh it's really special i mean they look
up to us uh you know when i was in high
school i i mean i'm from buffalo new
york so i was a big buffalo bills fan
growing up so i obviously was looking up
to everyone on the buffalo bills when i
was in high school and uh just uh you
know giving such an award to such an
incredible athlete claire i mean what
she has accomplished is just amazing and
uh just uh
you know show her the greatness and and
past pass it down to her and uh just
recognize her unbelievable talents is
great
i think claire was a little star struck
gronk what advice do you because she was
like oh my god she was trying to keep it
cool but she was definitely starstruck
what advice do you have it for advice
what advice you have for athletes like
claire you were in her position once
oh yes um especially um you know through
that high school level is to work hard
you know build
that foundation the building blocks to
get you to the next level uh obviously
you got to do your schoolwork get good
grades that's the first part in order to
stay eligible and uh to keep
participating and on top of it work hard
uh you know get in the weight room build
your strength listen to your coaches
learn as much as you possibly can
because if you don't even make it to the
top level you can take so much what you
have learned throughout your high school
career and your college career and apply
it to the next chapter of your life
after that
and gronk we're looking forward to
sunday you hosting the usa today high
school sports awards but a lot of people
are looking forward to sundays during
the fall so you're retired from football
again which we don't believe which we
don't believe your agent and your
girlfriend camille they both say they're
a little skeptical about you staying
retired so listen talk to me man it's
just me and you nobody else is watching
and coming
stuff yep football players and stuff
it's a football player are you ready i
mean will you stay away
yes yes i'm i'm retired now actually
camille made a comment because i i sent
her a picture one time the last week i
was in my brother's warehouse uh he
started a company ice shaker and i was
in the warehouse and i sent her a
picture of me in the warehouse and she's
like that's boring you should go back to
football
that's a lot more exciting and i was
like well what do you mean it's less
stress on me
i'm not i could i can't get injured in
this warehouse and uh it was just a
little joke and uh it was just funny at
the time but uh no i'm retired um i'm
like you now nate you know we're staying
retired and we're both on tv right now
together
but what if tom brady calls gronk you
know we just showed a video of you
crossing the touchdown crossing the goal
line i can't imagine what great feeling
that is what if tom brady called and
said i really need you again one more
time you you're telling us you'd really
say nope
well that was a cool video showing that
touchdown the super bowl that did get me
excited
no doubt about that but um
i i i would answer the phone call
obviously
[Laughter]
and
i i would you know talk to him chat with
him but i don't think i would go back to
football but uh i would definitely
answer the call
and uh
send them an eye shaker because that's
where i'm working now
okay all right all right i see what you
did there plug in the brand well listen
even if you don't go back you had one
hell of a career you are truly one of
the best of all time we appreciate you
joining us rob gronkowski you can watch
the usa today high school sports awards
this sunday on their website